and then there was a there's a few other
ceremonies and stuff and uh there's one
thing with like your elders or something
yeah so
um so after the monk thing
um there's this ceremony uh then we get
to the fun part there's a ceremony which
um is called uh Gun Mark which how can I
describe this ceremony the best way I
can describe it it's kind of like repl
replicating old ancient traditions where
you present the groom to the household
of the brides right
um so what happens is uh you separate
the two households you separate the two
families which is what we did Sydney's
family was in my house and uh we had
walked to our neighbor's house yeah and
if he can call that a house if you can
call that a house yeah some some of our
neighbors got pretty wild with their
house more like a Disneyland looking
Place yeah it was kind of wild yeah it's
like what the hell yeah and so what
happens is
um you separate the two houses you have
the groom side and you have the bride
side and the whole concept is all the
groom side has to come together to help
the groom kind of be able to prove to
the bride's family that they are worthy
to marry the bride right
um it was basically an escort Mission it
was an escort Mission thought like we
went my parents went full like force
were there were they
um they hired like traditional dancers
and like traditional like musicians uh
so we separated the houses and then you
started off with like kind of like a
king kong Tarzan kind of charts yeah you
know that starts off the uh Drums of
smack the drums are smacking about the
front day we had like some traditional
Thai dancers it felt super weird yeah
I'll I'll be honest crazy it was so fun
though they were just like go here guy
yeah I was like what am I doing yeah I
don't know what I don't know what the
[__] yeah economy indictis were given
like a Play-Doh like desserts or
something we're just like hold this and
I'm like I don't know what's happening
and then the drums stopped playing I'm
like oh okay I guess we're going yeah
and so basically my boys just escorted
me to the the bride's house yeah and so
you stop at the gate
um and I thought I was meant to talk uh
but no my mother my mother was
apparently doing the one all the talking
this is your this is your mums
step aside son uh and she basically she
has to kind of like negotiate uh with
the households to kind of like to kind
of like let let us into the house right
and uh with this procession there are
like there are three gates and there are
different trials that we need to do at
each gate and these trials are picked
like kind of not really at random but I
guess peaked by like the the whoever's
house oh yeah the bride's house so there
are different like how it traditionally
is
um because families are so big you'll
have different members of the bride's
house uh guarding each gate and they
will ask the groom to do whatever they
desire and this there's not like there's
not anything on paper where you know
traditionally you need to do do this
it's just whatever they feel like asking
for right it's kind of like yourself
yeah
kind of kind of like a little forfeit
basically yeah right and so at the first
gate
um my family I was asked uh to shout you
know I love Sydney as uh loud as I can
bear in mind there's like a hundred
people too like crowding around yeah
yeah this is like a lot of people yeah
this is a lot of people you get escort
to the first gate
um you get asked I got asked a shout out
I love Sydney so she can hear uh she she
can hear me because Sydney right now
she's not outside she's inside the house
right that's how that's how it's meant
to be it's kind of like kind of like
you're with your Bros and you're
invading a castle you know that's that's
kind of how it's meant to feel it's a
West Side Story yeah
feels like with stormy storming a castle
right
a lot of people yeah there's a lot
there's a lot of people uh I'm sure your
neighbors just joined in yeah yeah I
don't even know who these people were
yeah yeah yeah uh that was pretty easy
and then the second one
um the second the second game was a bit
more tricky because uh my family member
was like you got you're not doing this
alone you got to get your Bros involved
with this one no I'm holding the
desserts can't you see that I'm a
dessert holding account and I do not
want to involve myself in some frivolous
activity yeah and so she was like okay
you do 10 push-ups uh Jerry do 10
push-ups and Connor dance why why do I
have to dance yeah because at first it
was like gone do 10 push-ups and we're
all like yeah let's go not knowing that
we're about to be involved right yeah
and it's just like another 10. and then
God's like I'm like because I didn't the
boys didn't know anything about it yeah
I don't know nothing about this I'm just
like boys you got it you got to do this
for me boys please I'm just holding the
dessert yeah yeah so I did the 10
push-ups and then you know [__]
Connor and dinosaur like laughing at me
right thinking that they're gone
scot-free and then one of them was like
now one of you dance yeah
it was the weirdest thing I wish I'd
filmed this part because it was it was
so it was this bizarre situation of us
and a hundred plus Thai people around us
all watching Connor fortnite dance
it's like it's like a dream I can't
believe this has actually happened yeah
because it was so it really did feel
like we were storming a castle except
kind of was just Fortnight dancing in
front of the gates because we there was
this one interrogating yeah there was
this one
one bridge between like the outside and
the inside of the house that was over a
pond right and so Connor was just by
himself on this bridge
in front of like a hundred of like my
Thai family just like fortnite I'm like
I'm so glad to do the push-ups [__]
monks just left watching me you know
I've got this traditional tie dancers
dudes playing these Thai instruments
meanwhile she's a white guy dancing
wearing wearing jeans what a [__]
Bridge instead of 100 Thai people it was
so funny it's a weird experience yeah
but thankfully my Bros had my back
yeah I got in the second game and then
last gate was of chord guarded by
Sydney's family uh and they asked me to
uh sing oh yeah uh sing the song that I
sang for my very first dance uh with
Sydney uh which I'm pretty sure I sung
really really badly it's fine but it did
I I forgot to mention even though you
had to do these trials it was it's
normally ended with a with a little bit
of a bribe that's uh oh really yeah yeah
oh yeah I heard about that yeah did you
know because did you notice like when
they were like okay you're worthy and
I'm like okay thank you and I gave him
like an envelope yeah yeah she bribed
yeah I was like yeah I like this culture
yeah yeah
all I can say is you know Money Talks
you can be the most worthy man in the
world but you know a little bit of like
embarrass yourself and give us more what
if you had to like barter like best I
can do is
that happens actually that happens oh
really yeah that happens there's no news
10 bucks
we're packing it up yeah spot out we
didn't do this for our wedding but my
mom was like you know traditionally
sometimes it really depends on the
feeling of whoever's got in the gate
sometimes if they're feeling like oh
this uh this doesn't look like enough
money
slip an extra like 100 200 or something
like that that's so funny that's awesome
so yeah it's it's it's it's not meant to
be taken seriously it's just like it was
a lot of fun yeah awful all for fun very
casual
um and then after that uh is where you
had like the adult blessing ceremony
which is which is kind of what you see
with uh this yeah so what happens is you
uh you go into another room and the
immediate family all will take a seat
right and uh the basic the basic premise
is every one who is part of your
immediate family who is an elder to you
gets to bless your marriage which uh
every everyone takes one of these one of
these strings gives their blessings and
then literally like ties a knot ties a
knot for both me and for Sydney right
um now
uh I didn't know how long this was going
to last because yeah because I was like
you got a lot of Elders at the beginning
I was like you know Joey Connor died as
you know Emily you know come in have a
look and they saw you know both of our
parents blessing us tying the knots yeah
um and then I forgot to tell them that
uh this my entire family who was sitting
down waiting their turn they're gonna
come up and bless me as well so that you
were there standing there for like what
15 minutes or something yeah it was like
15-20 minutes before I was like oh yeah
um you guys go away from it yeah
before I went
so as as you can see
um I mean I I like I like the ceremony
and everything but I'm glad that mostly
it was just my family there yeah
um because uh obviously a lot of
Sydney's family is in America uh because
if Sydney's family was there we would
have been there for [__] hours like
your whole album with my whole um yeah
yeah because uh Hey like everyone got
the chance to give that blessing and you
can always tell when you've been to like
a Thai wedding because this is kind of
like a just marriaged uh sorry just
married kind of symbol because you can
tell Southeast Asian families their arm
just gets filled up I was gonna say most
people when they go to Southeast Asia
and they come back they only have a
bunch of
some other ceremony where I think it was
something to do with elders but it
wasn't your dad and then your dad was
talking to me right and everyone was
being really quiet and I was like is it
okay if you talk this loudly to me and
then eventually your mom came up I was
like shut up
not to me to your dad because it was
like everyone was quiet in this room
watching uh I was one of your family uh
like blasphemy or something and then
yeah Dad just turns around and he goes I
even joined Thailand so far and I was
like oh well you know like a whisper
is it okay it was like wow that's pretty
good
you know your son's getting married he
probably pay attention to that that's so
funny
I think after my dad got his Blessing
out of the way yeah
it's like um the part of I'm getting the
party started yeah and then like in the
meanwhile like there's literally a line
of my elders just waiting waiting to do
it and my dad's just like we're gonna be
here a while
oh my God and then there was the one
after where with the water pouring one
yeah yeah so after after I got all my
eldest blessing then we have the chance
for everyone else who came to their
wedding to give Their Blessings as well
and so uh what happens is me and Sydney
sat down
and we had kind of like a yeah we had
like a a vase with a flower in front of
us and what the concept is is that
people can pour water over hands and
bless us for the start of a new marriage
yeah a lot of blessings
every year we are very blessed yeah you
blessed we blessed
yeah
um and you know everyone lines up once
again and uh they take they take a kind
of like a not a bucket of water but just
a little like vase of water and just
pour it over our hands and you can say
whatever you want
um I was there for me and Sydney were
there for like 40 minutes
the part that I thought was kind of
funny was that like uh I think you it
was your mom or your aunt that said like
you know to all the English speakers who
were there like us was like okay uh so
you all have to line up in order from
oldest to youngest and I'm like I don't
know 90 of the people here how the [__]
am I supposed to know who's older and
younger than me so I'm just like I'll
just wait till the end you guys can all
go ahead but like I remember I didn't
know that we had to like say something
to you guys right like as we were
pouring the water so it got to my turn
and I'm just like oh [__] I haven't
thought about what to say to you guys I
don't remember what I said to you but I
said to Sydney I'm just like thinking
what they're saying and I think I ended
up just saying uh have a good life and
I'm like that sounds like a threat
enjoy the next 24 hours
it's like I didn't mean it to say it
like that I'm just like I didn't know
what to say and I'm just like oh [__] I
should just say that sorry have a good
time
have a good life what the [__] does that
mean
yeah no it's good though yeah but like
I'm a [__] man I I remember during
because we were sitting there for so
long just getting it just getting
blessed um I remember turning to Sydney
and I was like this is the weirdest
signing ceremony I've ever I've ever
been to because it literally felt like a
signing session at a convention except
everyone was just washing my hands so
many people washed my hands this one at
this one ceremony that my hands were
wrinkly but yeah I I I I had the prune
hands yeah the prune hands all the way